[Music]
jojo siwa is spilling some tea
the singer reveals the rudest celebrity
she's encountered and drumroll
it's candace cameron beret
incredibly shocked
jojo jumped on the tic toc trend where
users quickly flashed photos of celebs
and categorized them
one of the topics rudest celebrity i've
ever met
that's when she made the split second
reveal with a pic of the full house star
but nothing gets by eagle-eyed fans who
were able to decipher the celeb in
question with a screenshot sometimes i
feel like they just want the drama
it's not clear when exactly jojo's
unpleasant interaction with candice took
place but we do know back in 2016 the
pop star attended the fuller house
premiere
[Music]
now the viral clip has already racked up
over 15 million views
jojo captioned it quote pool day equals
exposed
and she sure exposed her real feelings
including which celeb quote did her
dirty
and that one goes to
spongebob squarepants
all right get it together old boy
for those asking how jojo could have
beef with the iconic sponge well she
might have called out the fictional
character in a jab at nickelodeon
jojo claimed she wasn't invited to the
network's 2022 kids choice awards
i'm not sure why
but i just didn't get an invite but it's
not all bad blood the tick tock also
unveils the nicest celeb jojo's met
miley cyrus
her celeb crush zendaya and the coolest
elton john
i love them meanwhile just last month
jojo was the subject of another moment
on social media when online trolls
slammed her as one of the newest judges
to join so you think you can dance
everything worked together today for you
on this stage and it was brilliant
but jojo doesn't shy away from the
criticism as she told e.t
she embraces it listen i'm the first one
to hate on myself like you cannot tell
me anything that i haven't already told
myself however
when you are saying something about me
that is blatantly
not true
that drives me mad i grew up in a dance
studio literally from the time i was who
i did my first solo then i went to
beyond dancing with the stars now i'm a
judge on so you think you can dance i
could tell you about every dance style i
could tell you moves and everything else
i could choreograph you would dance in
every dance style am i the smartest
dancer in the world by no means am i the
most knowledgeable in the whole world by
no means
but am i smart enough to be a judge on
so you think you can dance absolutely
[Music]
you